DAD.
I LOVE YOU, AS WELL.
>>> THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT."
I GOT A LOT TO TALK ABOUT, A
LOT, A LOT, A LOT.
HERE IS THE BIGGEST THING ON MY
MIND RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT?
WHEN I SAY, WHEN PEOPLE SAY
PROTEST TOO MUCH, WHAT IS HE
TRYING TO HIDE?
WHY IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SO DETERMINED
TO KEEP JANUARY 6th THAT
COMMITTEE FROM FINDING OUT WHAT
HE AND HIS ALLIES WERE DOING
BEFORE AND DURING THE
INSURRECTION AT CAPITOL HILL?
WHY, OH, WHY, OH WHY?
OUR BREAKING NEWS.
THE WHITE HOUSE SLAPPING DOWN
HIS CLAIMS OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE SAYING AND I QUOTE,
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP ABUSED
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY AND
ATTEMPTED TO SUBVERT A PEACEFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS REPRESENTED
A UNIQUE THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY
THAT CAN'T BE SWEPT UNDER THE
RUG AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
DETERMINED, THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS OF THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
SHOULD NOT BE USED TO SHIELD
INFORMATION THAT REFLECTS A
CLEAR AND APPARENT EFFORT TO
SUBVERT THE CONSTITUTION.
THAT IS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
SPOKESPERSON MIKE GWEN.
SO, PRESIDENT BIDEN HIMSELF
MIXED THE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
CLAIMS AS THE FORMER PRESIDENT
FILED A LAWSUIT, OF COURSE, IN
D.C. DISTRICT COURT TODAY
AGAINST A JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
AND THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES AS
PART OF HIS CAMPAIGN TO KEEP
RECORDS FROM HIS PRESIDENCY
SECRET.
AND HE MAY BE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME BECAUSE THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES TELLING HIM THEY'LL
TURNOVER THE RECORDS TO CONGRESS
IN LESS THAN ONE MONTH UNLESS
THE COURT INTERVENES.
TRUMP'S LAWYERS CALLING THE
REQUEST QUOTE AN ILLEGAL FISHING
EXPEDITION.
THIS IS NO FISHING EXPEDITION.
THIS IS BRINGING TO LIGHT WHAT P
HAPPENED ON ONE OF THE DARKEST
DAYS IN HISTORY.
WHEN BLOOD THIRSTY RIOTERS
STORMED THE CAPITOL BEATING
POLICE TRYING TO OVERTURN OUR
FREE AND FAIR ELECTION.
THE COMMITTEE SENDING A LETTER
TO STEVE BANNON FOR FAILING TO
COMPILE AND DISMISSING HIS CLAIM
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND ONE
OF ONLY TWO REPUBLICANS ON THE
COMMITTEE SAYS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT COULD FACE A SUBPOENA.
>> IF WE SUBPOENA ALL OF A
SUDDEN THE FORMER PRESIDENT, WE
KNOW THAT'S GOING TO BECOME KIND
OF A CIRCUS.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY SOMETHING
WE WANT TO DO UP FRONT BUT IF HE
HAS PIECES OF INFORMATION WE
NEED, WE CERTAINLY WILL.
>> WE GOT A LOT MORE TO COME ON
THIS, BELIEVE THAT.
WE HAVE MORE TO COME.
BUT AS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT,
THE NEWS THAT SHOCKED SO MANY
PEOPLE TODAY, THE DEATH OF
GENERAL COLIN POWELL.
A MAN WHO DEVOTED HIMSELF TO HIS
COUNTRY THROUGH A LIFETIME OF
FIRSTS.
THE NATION'S FIRST BLACK
SECRETARY OF STATE.
THE FIRST BLACK CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS.
THE FIRST BLACK NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE TOLD ME.
THIS IS BACK IN 2009.
HE'S TALKING TO ME ABOUT BARACK
OBAMA.
THIS IS AFTER BARACK OBAMA THE
CANDIDATE HE ENDORSED AFTER
SERVING IN THE REGAN AND GEORGE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION BECAME THE
FIRST BLACK PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HERE IT IS.
>> WE NOW HAVE A MAN WHO IS
PRESIDENT WHO IS AFRICAN
AMERICAN, BUT LET US NOT REST ON
THAT PEDESTAL.
LET'S RECOGNIZE WE HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU IN
SOMEWAY CONTRIBUTED TO WHERE WE
ARE NOW, THAT MOMENT, THIS NEW
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK I DID BUT I'M NOT
BRAGGING ABOUT IT BECAUSE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS COP
--
CONTRIBUTED.
I CONTRIBUTED IN A VISIBLE WAY
BY BECOMING THE FIRST SECRETARY
AND NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
AND CHAIRMAN THAT WAS BLACK BUT
I WAS GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY.
I'M MORE IMPRESSED BY THOSE WHO
CAME BEFORE ME WHO COULD HAVE
DONE THE SAME THING I DID BUT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE OF RACISM AND
SEGREGATION AND JIM CROW BUT
THEY STILL FOUGHT.
>> UH-UH.
AND LISTEN, WE HAVE SOMETHING
NEW TONIGHT ABOUT WHAT COLIN
POWELL SAID.
THIS MAY HAVE BEEN HIS LAST
INTERVIEW SPEAKING OPENLY WITH
BOB WOODWARD ABOUT HIS HEALTH
STRUGGLES IN AN INTERVIEW FOR
THE BOTH "PERIL".
>> YOU SEE, I GOT TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL ABOUT TWO OR THREE
TIMES A WEEK.
I HAVE CANCER AND I'VE GOT
PARKINSONS DISEASE BUT OTHERWISE
I'M FINE.
>> OH, NO.
I'M SO SORRY.
>> DON'T FEEL SORRY FOR ME.
I'M 85 YEARS OLD.
GOT TO HAVE SOMETHING.
I HAVEN'T LOST A DAY OF LIFE
FIGHTING THESE TWO DISEASES.
I'M IN GOOD SHAPE.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
YOU'VE NEVER LOST A DAY OF LIFE.
I MEAN, THINK OF THE ACTIVISTS
GENERALS, FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE AND NOW ORACLE, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YES.
>> WOW.
WHAT AN ATTITUDE, RIGHT?
I'M 85 YEARS OLD.
I HAVE TO HAVE SOMETHING.
AMAZING.
AMAZING ATTITUDE.
YOU KNOW, THAT WAS JUST THREE
MONTHS AGO.
THE MILITARY MAN IN THE FIGHT OF
HIS LIFE WHILE DOWN PLAYING WHAT
HE WAS GOING THROUGH.
TONIGHT, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES JOE BIDEN PAYING
TRIBUTE.
>> NOT ONLY A DEAR FRIEND AND
PATRIOT, ONE OF OUR GREAT
MILITARY LEADERS AND A MAP OF
OVERWHELMING DECENCY.
THIS IS A GUY BORN A SON OF
IMMIGRANTS IN NEW YORK CITY
RAISED IN HARLEM IN THE SOUTH
BRONX, GRADUATED FROM CITY
COLLEGE IN NEW YORK.
AND ROSE TO THE HIGHEST RANKS
NOT ONLY IN THE MILITARY BUT
ALSO IN AREAS OF FOREIGN POLICY
AND STATE CRAFT.
>> QUENY GRADUATE.
I AM, TOO.
I GOT TO SPEAK TO HIM ABOUT THAT
IN PERSON.
SO NEWS OF COLIN POWELL'S DEATH
BREAKING ABOUT 8:00 THIS MORNING
AND WITHIN MINUTES AT THE FOX
PROPAGANDA NETWORK, THEY WERE
SAYING THIS.
>> THERE WILL BE MANY
CONVERSATIONS IN THE WAKE OF THE
DEATH.
THEY WILL BE HONORING THIS MAN,
THIS PUBLIC SERVANT AND A
PROFESSIONAL SOLDIER FOR 35
YEARS.
WE CAN REFLECT ON HIS LIFE AND
WE SHOULD.
THERE WILL ALSO BE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE FACT HE WAS FULLY
VACCINATED ACCORDING TO HIS
FAMILY AND DIED FROM
COMPLICATIONS FROM COVID.
>> MINUTES.
LITERALLY MINUTES AFTER WE
LEARNED OF THE DEATH OF A MAN
WHO DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO
SERVING
THIS COUNTRY, MINUTES LATER
USING HIS DEATH TO RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT VACCINES.
THAT WASN'T THE END OF IT.
IT GOES ON.
>> WE'RE SEEING DATA FROM
EUROPE, THE UNITED KINGDOM, THE
FULLY VACCINATED PEOPLE ARE
BEING HOSPITALIZED AND FULLY
VACCINATED PEOPLE ARE DYING FROM
COVID AND HERE WE HAVE A HIGH
PROFILE EXAMPLE THAT WILL
REQUIRE MORE TRUTH, MORE TRUTH
FROM OUR GOVERNMENT, OUR HEALTH
LEADERS, AS WELL.
AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS STORY ON A
DAY STATE AFTER STATE AND
INSTITUTION AFTER INSTITUTION
ARE PUSHING MANDATES FOR
VACCINATION.
>> SERIOUSLY?
I GUESS -- YEAH, DON'T BE
FOOLED.
NEVER LEARN.
DON'T KNOW ANY BETTER.
I DON'T KNOW.
DON'T HAVE THE CHOPS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
JUST -- WITH A NATURAL INSTINCT
NOT TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE, YOU KNOW, ANY
DESCENT HUMAN BEING, NO, YOU
JUST DON'T -- YOU KNOW.
AT LEAST THAT'S HOW MY MAMA
RAISED ME.
A MAN JUST DIED AND THIS GUY
CAN'T WAIT TO MAKE IT INTO A
FIGHT ABOUT VACCINE MANDATES?
IT IS DISGRACEFUL.
AND THEN, IN A TWICE DELETED
TWEET FOX' JOHN ROBERTS SAID THE
FACT THAT COLIN POWELL DIED FROM
A BREAKTHROUGH COVID INFECTION
RAISES NEW CONCERNS HOW
EFFECTIVE VACCINES ARE LONG
TERM.
HE WENT ON TO SAY THAT HE
DELETED HIS TWEET BECAUSE PEOPLE
INTERPRETED IT AS ANTI-VAX.
OKAY.
THAT WAS HIS DEFENSE.
LOOK, THAT'S THE ORIGINAL TWEET
AGAIN.
DO YOU WANT FACTS?
SO I WILL GIVE YOU SOME FACTS.
COLIN POWELL'S DEATH DOESN'T
RAISE NEW CONCERNS ABOUT
THEFECTIVENESS OF VACCINES.
THE FACT IS COLIN POWELL, A
SOLDIER TO THE END, WAS BATTLING
MULTIPLE MYLOEMA WHICH IS A
CANCER OF THE CELLS THAT MAKE
ANTIBODIES.
HE ALSO HAD PARKINSONS WHICH PUT
HIM AT HIGH RISK WITH AN IMMUNE
COMPROMISED SYSTEM MAKING HIM
MUCH MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
VIRUS.
DOCTORS SAY WHAT COLIN POWELL'S
DEATH SHOWS IS THIS.
VACCINATING EVERYONE IS
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT CANCER
PATIENTS.
YOU GET VACCINATED FOR YOURSELF
BUT GET VACCINATED TO PROTECT
THE VULNERABLE PEOPLE LIKE
GENERAL POWELL.
THAT WOULD BE A FITTING TRIBUTE
TO HIS LEGACY OF SERVICE.
COLIN POWELL WAS A MAN OF
CHARACTER AND A MAN OF INTEGINI
INTEGRITY, A PERMANENT BLOT ON
HIS RECORD IN THE 2003 SPEECH
SAID PROVED IRAQ MISLED
INSPECTORS AND HID WEAPONS OF
MASS DESTRUCTION.
TWO YEARS LATER, A REPORT SAID
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WAS
DEAD WRONG.
>> I REGRET IT NOW BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION WAS WRONG.
OF COURSE, I DO.
I'LL ALWAYS BE SEEN AS THE ONE
THAT MADE THE CASE BEFORE THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
I SWAYED PUBLIC OPINION.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
>> AGAIN, THIS IS HIM OWNING UP
TO WHAT HE LATER CALLED ONE OF
HIS MOST MOMENTOUS FAILURES, THE
ONE WITH THE WIDEST RANGING
IMPACT.
SO THAT'S WHAT DESCENT PEOPLE
DO.
THAT'S WHAT CARING PEOPLE DO,
EMPATHETIC PEOPLE LEADERS.
WE MAKE A MISTAKE, WE ADMIT IT.
WE DO IT ALL THE TIME HERE A